why don't we begin
with the kyle rittenhouse trial which is
finally opened this of course is the
trial of the 17 year old at least he was
17 year old at the time
young man who was in kenosha wisconsin
he was there to
help with medical care for people on the
ground and also to prevent rioters from
burning down businesses and burning cars
and such and the entire situation ended
with three people shot and two people
dead kyle rittenhouse has been charged
now with murder there's one problem
there's no case against calrtton house
and there really is no case at all
against kyle written house they brought
up a sort of minor gun charge that one
is a little more controversial but the
murder case just it never existed and
the fact that this was ever brought to
trial just demonstrates how political
our judicial system sometimes is it
demonstrates that if a prosecutor gets
it in their head that they must
prosecute somebody regardless of the
facts on the ground they will do so even
when the case just simply does not exist
and we know that the case against
written house doesn't exist because the
prosecution yesterday brought forth a
bunch of witnesses and they all
promptly testified to written house's
self-defense case and so written house's
argument is that he shot the people who
were threatening him in self-defense and
the prosecution really really struggled
because it turns out that we knew from
the very first day right as soon as the
video footage emerged we knew exactly
what was going on in the written house
case and it was that he had shot people
in self-defense so for example
this entire incident the timeline of the
kyle rittenhouse incident started when
written house essentially was chased
down the street by some people who are
threatening him
and a gunshot was fired in the air he
turned around and there was a guy who's
lunging for him and so he shot the guy
here's video this is courtesy of abc
news this is video from that night this
is the first shooting
a man who police identified as
rittenhouse runs across the parking lot
of an auto service shop followed by a
shirtless man who was later identified
as joseph rosenbaum
moments later shots ring out
okay now you can stop it right there you
heard a shot before the narrator says
moments later shots ring out
okay well
that first shot was actually not written
house that was somebody who's chasing
him firing a shot into the air
rittenhouse is running away has no idea
where the shot's coming from then it
turns out that rosenbaum who it also
turns out was a career criminal is
chasing him down and is lunging for his
gun
okay so that is shooting number one
okay so now we move on to shooting
number two ridden house is now being
chased down the street by a bunch of
nerd duels and um and they physically
assault him and there one person comes
at him with a gun he shoots that guy in
the arm another person tries to hit him
in the face with a skateboard he shoots
him and kills him right here is that
video again this is all on video guys
he falls down
you can see he raises the gun there's
somebody trying to hit him with the
skateboard
he shoots he shoots the guy
and then there's a guy who approaches
him he has a pistol in his hand right
the guy approaching him has a pistol in
his hand
hey so all of that is on video right
uncontroverted it's on video
pretty clearly and obviously a case of
self-defense the prosecution is trying
to argue that written house started the
fight the written house essentially
insulted a guy or tried to initiate
conflict with rosenbaum who's originally
chasing him and the big problem is that
it's pretty clear that's not what
happened and there's fbi inferred video
so it turns out the fbi has eyes on
nearly everything happening in the
united states apparently we never saw
this video until now
and you can see from the video exactly
how this went down
so you have person of interest one and
person of interest two
and you see that they're having some
sort of conversation between the cars
and then person of interest two starts
running away being chased by person of
interest one
so what the prosecution is attempting to
claim is that person of interest one who
is rosenbaum was confronted
by written house but that's not what the
testimony of the prosecution's own
witnesses said
they said that it's precisely the
opposite so there's a witness named ryan
belch and he was again he was called by
the prosecution
this guy was not called by the defense
and ryan belch says in open testimony
that rosenbaum had said earlier that if
he caught ridden house alone he would
kill him
hey that's not the prosecutors called
this guy this is their case the
prosecutors here we go
when i turned around
rosenbaum was right there in front of my
face yelling and screaming
and
i would say dude back up just chill
i don't know what your problem is and he
goes you know what if i catch any of you
guys alone tonight i'm gonna kill you
and he said that to you correct
did he say that to the defendant as well
the defendant was there
so yes
that's the prosecutor's witness
whoops
that's not good
now again this is all undercut the
entire prosecution case here was
undercut by all the footage from the
evening of in fact the prosecutors tried
to bar testimony and bar actual video of
written house talking before any of this
happened because there's video from
written house earlier in the night
talking about why he was there in
kenosha wisconsin in the first place
this does not sound like a guy who went
out to shoot some people in the middle
of a riot
so people are getting injured and our
job is to protect this business and part
of my job is to also help people if
there's somebody hurt i'm running into
harm's way that's why i have my rifle
because i protect myself obviously
we're protecting from the citizens and i
just got pepper sprayed by a
person in the crowd
so you had non-lethal but you just
respond we don't have non-lethal
so you guys are full on ready to defend
the property
yes we are now if i can ask can you guys
step back medical ems right here
okay so then the prosecution and then
goes in this video he's trying to help
one of the writers
then the the prosecution tries to bring
a second witness there's a guy named
richie mcginnis who's a reporter for the
daily caller who you can see in the
original video who is following after
rittenhouse and uh and rosenbaum as they
are running down the street and after
rosenbaum's shot you can see richard
mcginnis take off his shirt and try and
provide some sort of medical care for
rosenbaum and so the prosecutor tries to
ask richard mcginnis so he was falling
over rosenbaum when he was shot right
like he just he tripped and then he was
wrongfully shot by rittenhouse and he
was shot for for no reason because he
was just falling over and then
rittenhouse wanted to kill him so he
killed him so it's not self-defense and
richard mcguinness is like well no
actually let me explain
i kind of caught up to them um i was
running a bit faster and so
uh at the time initially i was probably
30 feet back when the first when
everybody first started running but then
by the time i arrived in the lot i was
feet and you continue to be behind mr
rosenbaum at the time that the defendant
shot and killed him correct
um i did alter my trajectory a little
bit
when i
saw mr rittenhouse turn around and saw
mr rosenbaum
plunging for the front portion of the
rifle
lunging for the front portion of the
rifle and the prosecutor tries to push
him and tries to say well was he falling
over and and the witness says
no he said f-u and reached for the
weapon
so yeah not
not great not great bob for the for the
prosecution now the way the media are
trying to portray this is as though it's
just a sort of a conflict of visions the
associated press says jurors heard
starkly different portrayals of kyle
rittenhouse instigator or victim in
opening statements at his trial on
tuesday on charges of shooting three
people on the streets of kenosha during
a turbulent protest against racial
injustice a prosecutor said rittenhouse
set the bloodshed in motion when he
triggered a confrontation with a man
that night and then killed him with a
bullet to the back rittenhouse's
attorney told the jury his client acted
in self-defense after the man tried to
grab written house's gun and others
kicked the teen in the face and clubbed
him in the head with the skateboard if
one of those stories is true and one of
those stories is not and the prosecution
story is not true and then they called a
bunch of witnesses who ripped apart
their own case this thing never should
have been in front of a jury given the
fact that the prosecution case is just a
complete crap show here why exactly was
it brought in the first place and the
answer is because we live in a society
where the media will not allow a case
not to be brought so long as the
purported
victimizer is of the wrong political
persuasion okay there is no way that if
this were a left-wing person who had
shot a couple of proud boys in the
streets and the video were available
like this that this prosecution has ever
brought it is just too weak a case
politics unfortunately is now telescoped
into individual cases of justice
we're no longer a country where
individual cases are seen for what they
are judged on their fact patterns judged
on their merits instead the outside
politics of the players are telescoped
into the proceedings
and that is exactly the wrong way to do
this right due process of law requires
precisely the opposite we saw this a lot
with the derrick chauvin trial in
minnesota regardless of what you think
of derrick shawn's activities that day
and now the man has been convicted of
murder and regardless of what you think
of the activities there is still no
evidence in the derek shoving case that
anything he did was motivated by racism
it didn't matter it turned into a giant
national referendum on whether police
across the country were racist despite
the fact there was no evidence that
chopin himself was racist or had done
anything racist as opposed to just
egregiously wrong in the confrontation
with george floyd
and everything is used as a stand-in for
politics these days and the written
house trial is just a perfect example of
that because again the prosecution has
so little a case that they are calling
witnesses who are rebutting the
prosecution case and they can't stop it
if somehow written house is convicted
here on the basis of the evidence that's
being presented you can only chalk that
up to politics because there's literally
no way to watch the testimony that's
being given and not see that that's a
self-defense case
who's got two thumbs and wants you to
like and subscribe